Angela Merkel is the Chancellor of
Germany Europe's largest economy she is
an unglamorous leader and often
underrated that has a sharp analytical
mind she's not one to back down from a
good fight and can be surprisingly
decisive this is a brief history of
Angela Merkel 1954 Hamburg has been
devastated by world war ii anglich
Asner's born germany is in the midst of
the Cold War standoff between the
Soviets in the West against the wave of
migrants Angela's pastor father moves
the family to a small farming village in
the communist piece 1957 the Kassner
family moves again to Temple in East
Germany a market town of 20,000 Angela's
father sets up a Theological Seminary
1961 the Berlin wall goes up kazna
remembers her mother crying in church
1973 Kassner graduates from high school
she moves to Leipzig to attend
University she studies physics the only
subject she'd failed in high school
1977 Kasner marries fellow physics
student Ulrich Merkel and takes his name
they moved to Berlin 1982 Angela
divorces Ulrich she keeps his name 1986
Merkel completes her PhD in quantum
chemistry she meets Joaquim Sauer her
second husband 1989 the Berlin Wall
Falls and so does East Germany's
communist regime Merkel is working out
of physics labs she joins a crowd
pushing past guards into West Berlin she
becomes involved in East Germany's
pro-democracy movement
1990 Lothar de Maiziere becomes East
Germany's last Prime Minister he chooses
Merkel to be his deputy press secretary
she ends up joining the West German
political party the Christian Democratic
Union in the first election of a
reunited Germany she wins a seat in
parliament 1991 Merkel is appointed
Federal Minister for women and youth
under Chancellor Helmut Kohl wanted an
Easterner and a woman on his cab in 1994
Merkel is promoted to minister for the
environment and nuclear safety 1998 :
ministration is defeated in election and
rocked by scandal Merkel surprises her
own party and swoops in to become its
secretary-general and later the
chairperson 2005 in a special election
Merkel narrowly defeats Gerhard
schröder's Social Democratic Party
becoming Germany's first female
Chancellor 2008 the financial crisis
takes hold in the US and Europe Merkel
bails out Germany's banks she also
commits to fiscal austerity to deal with
growing debt 2009 Merkel wins a second
term 2010 Germany's economy recovers
faster than that of any other country in
Europe Merkel helps craft a bailout for
Greece holding the eurozone together
2013 thanks largely to a stable German
labor market Merkel wins a third term in
a landslide victory 2014 crisis breaks
out in Ukraine Merkel is forced to
confront Vladimir Putin over Russia's
actions 2015 against the wishes of her
party Merkel accepts growing numbers of
refugees from the Middle East she urges
the rest of the EU to follow suit Merkel
has kept her style of leadership modest
and plain-spoken
but she has edged Germany into a more
assertive role during the 10 years as
Chancellor
you